de nouveaux bombardements sont en cours
dans l'est de l'ukraine les etats-unis
redoutent une attaque de la russie dans
les prochains jours la russie annonce au
contraire poursuivre ces retraits
militaire le retrait des chars déployés
près de la frontière ukrainienne qui
retournent dans leurs garnisons retrouve
tout de suite elena volochine notre
correspondante à moscou le président
russe vladimir poutine annoncent des
manoeuvres de ses forces stratégiques
pour demain ces manoeuvres et est elle
prévue
alors le ministère russe de la défense
affirme que ces manoeuvres qui seront
des exercices étaient effectivement des
manoeuvres planifié donc des exercices
prévus fait inédit cependant x elles se
dérouleront sous la supervision directe
de vladimir poutine alors en l'espèce il
s'agira de le ministère l'a précisé de
tirs de missiles balistiques et de
missiles de croisière seront impliqués
dans ces exercices les forces
aérospatiale le district fédéral sud les
forces spatiales stratégique les flottes
de la mer baltique et de la mer noire
autrement dit celles qui sont basés en
crimée annexée le but selon annoncé
serait de vérifier les capacités de
l'appareil de commandement militaire du
calcul des cibles à des équipages de la
flotte mais aussi la solidité des
armements nucléaires et non-nucléaires
voilà donc pour l'aspect officiel alors
cette annonce intervient alors même que
vous le disiez il y a trois jours
appelle la russie à annoncé à la fin
d'une partie de ces exercices de grande
ampleur et le retrait partiel des armées
stationnées à la frontière
ukrainienne un retrait qui a été mise en
doute je le rappelle par l'occident
l'otan affirmant qu'au contraire la
russie serait en train de renforcer ses
capacités militaires à la frontière
ukrainienne cette hypothèse elle m'a été
confirmé ici par un expert militaire à
moscou qui surveille les manoeuvres et
les déplacements à des troupes russes il
m'a notamment montré des vidéos
d'acheminement de d'artillerie par voie
ferroviaire au moment même de l'annoncé
de ces retrait vers la frontière
ukrainienne il m'a aussi expliqué que et
s'agissant d'un retrait partiel de
nombreuses troupes dont on annonçait le
retour dans leurs bases de dislocation
permanente était justement avait
justement ses bases à la frontière même
avec l'ukraine donc un retrait qui
serait finalement un faux semblants et
moscou souffle le chaud et le froid
aujourd'hui avec cette news 'l'annonce
quelle est la stratégie actuelle du
kremlin
alors la stratégie du kremlin c'est de
dire qu'à aucun moment la russie net un
agresseur c'est celle finalement de
l'agresseur agressé parce que la russie
dit se défendre toujours 1 depuis le
début finalement de ce conflit dans
lequel elle a toujours nié jouer un rôle
et d'avoir déstabilisé la situation en
ukraine de l'est en encourageant en
armes en finançant ses forces
séparatistes aujourd'hui le discours de
moscou il est celui d'une double
agression contre la russie est contre le
monde russophone à l'est de l'ukraine
donc une partie de ce discours est
dirigée à dire que la russie serait
menacé par l'otan qui se rapprocherait
de ses frontières et l'autre partie de
ce discours consiste à dire que les
populations russophones à du crâne de
l'ess sont attaqués par les forces du
craignent n est donc qu il s'agirait
pour moscou de les défendre
l'ambassadeur russe hier à washington un
lien anatoli antonov est allé jusqu'à
dire que l'occident et les états unis
nier un génocide
qui se passerait à l'est de l'ukraine de
ces populations russophones par le
gouvernement de kiev un discours auquel
adhère en grande partie en majeure
partie la population russe je rappelle
qu'en russie seuls 4% des russes
estiment que la russie est responsable
de l' escalade 50% un blâme les états
unis et 16% le cren selon un récent
sondage merci beaucoup et léna volochine
pour votre analyse merci à vous